[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes bonsoir à tous merci
d'être avec nous sur TV 78 nous sommes
le jeudi 25 mai voici le programme de ce
soir quels sont les informations à
retenir aujourd'hui dans les Yvelines au
prisme d'Élancourt se déroule jusqu'à
demain le challenge skyrob nous
reviendrons également sur la démission
de la présidente du comité olympique
français Brigitte Enrique et enfin nous
ferons le point sur le tirage au sort de
Roland-Garros les détails avec notre
journaliste Céline Charles la Fête de la
Nature revient dans les Yvelines jusqu'à
dimanche partez à la découverte du
département et prenez un grand bol d'air
frais 77 lieux proposent des activités
et des animations nos invités nous
parlerons de leur rendez-vous et puis
comme d'habitude le jeudi à l'approche
du week-end nous vous donnerons nos
idées de sortie dans les Yvelines au
programme les prochaines brocantes dans
le département des festivals mais aussi
les spectacles les détails en fin
d'émission avec notre journaliste
Gabriel Gonthier c'est également le
dernier week-end pour profiter du 32ème
salon d'art de Montigny-le-Bretonneux 70
artistes exposent leurs œuvres ont fait
le point avec l'invité d'honneur
Christophe Beaudin et avec moi en
plateau des invités Véronique Morin
bonsoir bonsoir alors vous êtes délégué
à la promotion de la nature pour la
ville de plaisir ce week-end se déroule
la fête de la nature dans la ville
pourquoi c'est toujours aussi important
aujourd'hui de fêter la nature
aujourd'hui c'est important de fêter la
nature pour rappeler que cet
environnement est magnifique il faut
s'émerveiller malgré tout il est fragile
donc c'est son un des objectifs à
retenir Fabien Lambert bonsoir vous êtes
Eco garde pour la commune de Beynes et
vous aussi vous allez fêter la nature à
ben c'est demain après-midi pourquoi
c'est également un rendez-vous important
à Ben cette Fête de la Nature
c'est la première année que
il y aura une collaboration entre
storenji et la commune de Beynes Arben
est très soucieux de son environnement
notamment avec ses chemins sa forêt ces
rivières donc c'est pour ça que la Fête
de la Nature est un rendez-vous
important pour Ben donc on en parlera
plus en détail tout à l'heure avec nous
également sur ce plateau Christophe
Bodin bonsoir bonsoir alors vous êtes
artiste peintre et cette année vous êtes
l'invité d'honneur de la 32e du 32e
Salon des Arts de Montigny le Bretonneux
ça fait quoi ça représente quoi pour
vous d'être l'invité d'honneur de cet
événement c'est un honneur on est très
honoré parce que là quand on vient nous
chercher comme ça c'est toujours
toujours agréable c'est vrai qu'avec
Montigny ça fait quand même depuis 2008
que je participe régulièrement j'ai déjà
gagné des prix avec le salon d'art mais
c'est la première fois que je suis
invité d'honneur donc c'est vraiment une
très belle très belle opportunité et
puis une belle reconnaissance aussi donc
je les remercie beaucoup
de vos travaux et de votre exposition
dans quelques instants et enfin nous
sommes aussi accompagnés d'une
journaliste de la rédaction de TV 78
c'est l'inchal bonsoir bonsoir avec vous
on reviendra sur les informations à
retenir dans les Yvelines dans cette
émission également un festival dédié aux
étudiants notre chronique sur le
bien-être animal et le traditionnel quiz
du jeudi ce sera en fin d'émission mais
avant je vous propose de jeter un coup
d'oeil à la météo de demain
[Musique]
demain matin le soleil sera toujours au
rendez-vous dans les Yvelines les
températures commencent à être estivales
et fera 13 degrés le matin à Houdan
Rambouillet et Versailles et 14 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie dans l'après-midi le
soleil brillera toujours côté
température comptait environ 21 à 22
degrés en moyenne et demain nous
fêterons la saint Béranger le pont
maintenant sur les informations du jour
à retenir dans les Yvelines
et donc c'est avec vous Céline Charles
on commence par cette information la
présidente du comité olympique français
Brigitte Enrique démissionne de son
poste oui Mathilde et ce a un peu plus
d'un an des Jeux Olympiques Paris 2024
la Saint-Germain nois sort de Carlo
livre député de la douzième
circonscription des Yvelines a annoncé
sa démission ce jeudi matin à
l'ouverture d'une assemblée générale du
comité une décision qui intervient dans
un contexte compliqué l'instance
connaissait un conflit interne depuis
plus d'un an et demi notamment avec le
prédécesseur de Brigitte Enrique Denis
maseglia l'ex footballeuse a donc
préféré apaisé les tensions en quittant
ses fonctions c'est désormais Astrid
Guyard yvelinoise elle aussi qui
assurera l'intérim avant la prochaine
élection qui se tiendra dans les trois
prochains mois on continue avec du sport
Céline aujourd'hui avait lieu le tirage
au sort des tableaux féminins et
masculins au Grand Chelem parisien oui
on sait désormais qui joueront contre
qui joueront nos deux yvelinois engagés
pour Roland Garros la numéro une
Française Caroline Garcia originaire de
Saint-Germain-en-Laye jouera au premier
tour contre la Chinoise Chiu Wang Arthur
rinderknech ancien saint-germainois à
quant à lui était placé dans la partie
d'un autre Français Richard Gasquet et
alors aujourd'hui et jusqu'à demain se
déroule la nouvelle édition du Challenge
ski up au prisme d'Élancourt
skyrobe c'est quoi vous allez me dire
c'est un projet numérique scolaire qui
permet aux enfants de travailler
plusieurs domaines comme les
mathématiques le français les sciences
ou encore la technologie tout ça à
l'aide de robots alors comment comment
ça se passe concrètement et bien depuis
le mois de septembre 35 classes des
écoles de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et
plus largement des Yvelines ont appris à
coder et programmer des robots à rédiger
des articles de blog ou encore à écrire
un journal du programmateur le but étant
de développer plusieurs compétences de
façon ludique aujourd'hui et demain les
enfants présentent leurs résultats face
à un jury au prisme d'Élancourt écoutez
on est devant un bon exemple de
l'évolution de la pédagogie je vous
rappelle que 80% des métiers de demain
n'existent pas aujourd'hui et seront
liés au numérique donc ici on essaie
d'être plutôt en avance on est dans
Paris c'est clair
un des 8 territoires mondiaux de
l'innovation c'est une classe qui avait
besoin comme ça de projet un peu
fédérateur de pour travailler en
collectif parce qu'ils avaient justement
du mal à se concentrer et ça a vraiment
je trouve fonctionné parce que là ils
sont extrêmement calme extrêmement
investis et du coup ça ça a vraiment
développé chez eux ce côté on est tous
ensemble vers un objectif et on continue
ces informations du jour Céline avec la
Villa Savoie à Poissy qui pourrait être
le monument préféré des Français oui
elle est en compétition pour représenter
l'Île-de-France dans la célèbre émission
le monument préféré des Français
présenté bien sûr par Stéphane Bern
alors pour l'instant la Villa Savoie
imaginée par l'architecte Le Corbusier
et Pierre Jeanneret est en compétition
avec deux autres lieux de la région le
parc du domaine de la Vallée aux Loups
dans les hautes scènes et le site
Richelieu de la Bibliothèque de France à
Paris alors si vous voulez soutenir ce
monument yvelinois vous pouvez voter sur
le site de France Télévisions mais
attention il vous reste que que très peu
de temps les votes se terminent demain à
minuit et enfin l'abbaye des Hauts de
cernées en Vallée de Chevreuse recherche
son personnel pour octobre 203 oui au
total ce sont 200 postes qui sont à
pourvoir après 2 ans de travaux l'Hôtel
Restaurant racheté par Paris Society
doit rouvrir en octobre prochain et
puisqu'il fait peau neuve et bien son
personnel aussi la phase de recrutement
est lancée toutes sortes de profits sont
recherchés dans les domaines de la
restauration de la réception de
l'animation encore de la sécurité et de
la maintenance des job dating devrait
être organisés prochainement mais en
attendant plusieurs offres d'emploi sont
déjà retrouvées sur le site du groupe et
enfin l'actualité internationale rejoint
parfois l'actualité locale la mort de
Tina Turner survenu hier à fait remonter
des souvenirs à la ville de Versailles
dans un tweet elle a rappelé le concert
de la légende du rock qui s'est déroulée
le 28 juin 1990 au château de Versailles
alors à l'époque Mathilde c'était encore
en franc 170 francs le concert soit 26
26 € maintenant oui c'était vraiment pas
cher c'était vraiment pas cher comparé
au concert de maintenant merci beaucoup
c'est ninja et comme d'habitude si vous
aussi vous voyez une information ou une
image que vous a marqué près de chez
vous n'hésitez pas à nous la partager
sur les réseaux sociaux en utilisant le
hashtag 78
[Musique]
ce week-end la nature est à l'honneur
partout en France et les Yvelines ne
font pas exception jusqu'au dimanche 29
mai retrouvez des animations et des
activités dans 77 lieux du département
pour en parler avec nous Véronique Morin
délégué à la promotion de la nature pour
la mairie de plaisir et Fabien Lambert
pour la commune de Beynes alors avant de
parler de la Fête de la Nature et de vos
animations et activités respectives
Fabien Lambert est-ce que vous pouvez
nous expliquer ce qu'est un éco garde
évidemment alors un éco garde c'est à la
base un dispositif bénévole de bénévoles
qui sont là pour protéger et patrouiller
sur les les espaces naturels sensibles
du département pour ma part je suis
professionnel je suis engagé par la
commune directement donc je travaille
pour la mairie et donc je fais un petit
peu le même travail que c'est à dire que
je vais pas Trouiller sur les chemins
ruraux pour essayer de découvrir des
dépôts sauvages voilà
entretenir la faune la flore et puis
m'occuper de tout ce qui est à
l'environnement sur la commune
m'a permis vos missions il y avait cette
tâche aussi organisé la fête de la
nature à Beynes
contribue et puis je vais aussi tenir un
stand pendant la fête et alors quelles
seront les animations et les différentes
activités qu'on pourra faire de
l'après-midi à peine alors on a décidé
de baser la Fête de la Nature beaucoup
sur des sorties et puis pour pouvoir
découvrir
la ville et puis ces alentours donc on
aura aussi quelques stands sur la place
de la mairie donc pour les stands on
aura la ligue de protection des oiseaux
voilà un apiculteur aussi l'association
des plaines de Versailles qui seront
présentes avec une ruche numérique et
puis des produits locaux et enfin
l'entreprise eridique qui présentera les
copâturage avec de l'écopatural ça va
être un petit peu tout ce qui est
entretien des espaces verts grâce aux
ovins donc les moutons à l'échelle les
brebis il y aura notamment un guidage du
troupeau de 17 heures à 19h et alors à
plaisir il y a aussi des animations un
petit peu qui se regroupent il y aura
aussi un une animation une activité avec
les abeilles et notamment des
apiculteurs tout à fait en fait la fête
de la nature plaisir prend une forme
d'hiver c'est va toucher toutes les
générations nous avons commencé hier
avec les scolaires et puis les activités
pour tout public et nous continuons
vendredi samedi et dimanche avec
notamment des ateliers portés par nos
associations et notamment notre
association d'apiculteurs qui a
différents ruchers sur la commune donc
effectivement ce sera l'occasion de
présenter leur métier au grand public
mais nous recevons l'OPI samedi
après-midi lopie étant donc l'Office de
protection des insectes qui n'ont pas de
protection pardon l'office pour les
insectes et ils auront l'occasion de
permettre de découvrir en lors de balade
dans le parc du château la réalité de la
petite faune qui est présente et alors
justement depuis 2017 la maison des
insectes située à carrière-sous-poissy
sensibilise le public aux insectes entre
des goûts pour des piqûres ou la peur
des piqûres ou aspect effrayant les
craintes sont nombreuses pour ces petits
bêtes leur objectif est donc de faire
tomber les idées reçues je vous propose
de regarder le reportage de Julien Leroy
quelles sont les clichés qu'on peut
avoir sur les insectes il y a des
insectes qui sont quand même
désagréables les mouches qui font caca
partout et puis qui amène des maladies
souvent des araignées c'est pas beau ça
ça fait peur
de tout ce qui est volant par rapport à
la peur d'Épicure combattre les idées
reçues une des missions de l'office pour
les insectes et leur environnement en
2017 cette association a créé la maison
des insectes à carrière sous Poissy pour
permettre au public d'admirer de près
ces petites bêtes méconnues phasmes
fourmis ou papillon une cinquantaine
d'espèces sont présentées objectif
apprendre à s'émerveiller pour
démystifier l'univers obscur de ses
êtres vous y revenez avec plein d'a
priori si je vous montre certaines
blattes vous allez trouver si vous savez
pas que ce sont des blattes la plupart
du temps vous allez avoir une réaction
d'étonnement vous allez regarder vous
allez observer vous allez vous dire ah
c'est plutôt joli puis une fois qu'on
vous dit que c'est une blague vous avez
un mouvement de recul donc ça vous
montre quoi ça vous montre que c'est pas
la blague qui est sale mais c'est l'idée
que vous en avez prédateur naturel
recyclent des matières organiques ou
pollinisateurs les insectes ont une
place centrale dans les écosystèmes les
trois quarts de la diversité de notre
nourriture est directement liée à ces
êtres vivants quand vous reprenez une
pomme et que vous observez le cul de la
pomme vous avez ce qui reste d'une fleur
et cette pomme elle serait pas aussi
belle et certainement pas aussi grosse
s'il y a pas s'il y avait pas mal
d'insectes notamment des abeilles
sauvages qui étaient passées visiter les
fleurs nous notre rôle c'est bien ça
c'est de réussir à faire prendre
confiance à tout le monde que les
insectes ils ont une place qui est
extrêmement importante dans le
fonctionnement de la nature que nous on
je fais partie de la nature qu'on peut
pas vivre sans la nature et qu'on peut
donc pas vivre sans les insectes des
êtres fascinants et fragiles dont il
faut prendre soin selon une étude de
2017 les trois quarts des insectes
volants présents en Allemagne ont
disparu en près de 30 ans diminution de
leur habitat et pollution d'origine
humaine des animations sont proposées
avec Lopi dans cette maison pour
sensibiliser le public à ses
problématiques ce qui est absolument
inédit aujourd'hui c'est que on a une
espèce sur la planète qui est devenue
absolument prépondérante qui est l'homme
et qui a un impact tel quand on s'entend
il est capable de provoquer sa une crise
d'extinction qui est quasiment
comparable aux crises d'extinction qu'on
a pu connaître dans les temps
géologiques le premier levier que les
personnes ont c'est la première chose
qu'ils peuvent faire c'est agir
directement sur leur jardin laisser un
peu faire laisser un peu de sauvage dans
le jardin c'est déjà une action qui est
extrêmement importante et presque
militante aujourd'hui une visite ludique
et interactive pour mieux prendre
conscience des enjeux liés à ces espèces
chaque année le pissensibilise environ
20 000 personnes partout en France un
travail de fourmis pour permettre aux
petits et aux grands d'observer d'un œil
nouveau les insectes
alors j'ai l'impression qu'aujourd'hui
c'est de plus en plus important de
sensibiliser les personnes aux petits
animaux comme les insectes ou les
oiseaux c'est vraiment ce que vous
ressentez également que il faut faire
comprendre aux personnes que même les
petits animaux sont importants pour
l'écosystème
bah oui tout à fait après il y a pas que
les petits animaux c'est aussi tous les
biotopes et tout l'environnement sur
lesquels ils attraits mais c'est vrai
que il y a quelques années on voyait pas
forcément du faux challenge tardif parce
qu'on voulait que tout soit très bien
entretenu aujourd'hui on le voit dans
différentes villes voilà on sait que les
animaux ils ont besoin d'un
environnement plutôt calme et pas trop
perturbé par l'homme donc voilà c'est
c'est aussi pour ça qu'il faut les
sensibiliser les gens pour pour qu'ils
puissent comprendre que ces animaux ont
besoin de plantes et des pour vivre
oui on va insister en fait sur pour
notre part sur les insectes sur le ce
monde invisible qui est malgré tout
essentiel à la chaîne de de la nature et
on perçoit mal ou vit un insecte
finalement et effectivement comme vous
le disiez la démarche de fauche tardive
une gestion différenciée des espaces
verts qui est donc beaucoup plus en
fonction de l'usage qui est fait
lorsqu'on va avoir besoin d'un terrain
rat on va le faire comme ça pour pouvoir
pique-niquer en revanche lorsque
l'espace ne justifie pas c'est vraiment
bénéfique de pouvoir laisser la nature
s'épanouir et c'est ce qu'on veut
pouvoir montrer durant ces quatre
journées de sensibilisation et alors
tous les deux dans vos communes
respectives j'ai un peu épluché les
programmes il va y avoir des découvertes
nocturnes alors à Ben ce sera sur les
chauves-souris et à plaisir ce sera sur
les papillons de nuit c'est important
aussi de proposer ce type d'activité aux
citoyens
[Musique]
ça permet de sensibiliser en premier
lieu est-ce que ça peut vous intéresser
c'est ninja et Christophe Bodin c'est
animation qui sont proposées pour la
Fête de la Nature ça donne envie ça
donne envie c'est vrai que on imagine
bien déambuler dans la nuit avec des
petites lampes et puis découvrir un
monde qu'on connaît pas donc des animaux
finalement on connaît les chats les
chiens mais pas les chauves-souris
encore moins les insectes c'est ça donc
c'est très intéressant et alors vous
attendez beaucoup de monde
durant vos événements respectifs est-ce
que vous avez quantifié un petit peu
alors nous sur la totalité de du
week-end en termes d'atelier et
d'inscription on est près d'une centaine
de personnes pour ce qui est de
l'atelier de visite samedi après-midi
nous aurons la SPA et Lopi donc le
public pourra passer sans inscription et
de la même façon le dimanche matin les
élus de la commune de plaisir sont
toujours présents au marché couvert et
donc au travers différentes animations
il nous arrivent d'avoir des actions
particulières et cette année dans le
cadre de la Fête de la Nature les élus
proposeront un quiz nous sommes
accompagnés par la défile qui est
l'association de promotion de la
philatélie et de l'écrit qui propose
notamment aux enseignants un certain
nombre de documents dédiés à la nature
de sensibilisation donc il nous
accompagneront au faire de l'eau qui
seront à gagner et puis on va proposer
aux enfants de recomposer en direct avec
nous un pulse un pulse qui est en fait à
la à la dédiée aux abeilles solitaires
on connaît beaucoup l'abeille domestique
ce sera l'occasion de la découvrir sur
les ateliers mais en fait tout le monde
des pollinisateurs et très vaste et donc
il y a matière à le préserver un
programme riche Fabien Lambert vous
attendez à peu près combien de personnes
demain après-midi mais on a séparé la
Fête de la Nature en deux parties ça va
être une partie plutôt l'après-midi pour
les écoles en fait qui sont réservées
aux écoles donc on a plusieurs créneaux
pendant toute l'après-midi ou
différentes classes vont pouvoir tourner
entre les différents ateliers les
différentes sorties voilà on a déjà
commencé un petit peu aussi dans la
semaine pour pouvoir séparer
cette charge de travail et puis en
seconde partie de de soirée on a décidé
de faire ça le vendredi justement pour
éviter le d'avoir le domaine de
l'Ascension et donc on a organisé un
spectacle donc aura lieu
à côté de la place du marché à 18h donc
l'objectif c'est aussi de d'attirer le
monde justement avec ce spectacle et
qu'il puisse découvrir les stands les
activités au même moment et bien merci
beaucoup Véronique Morin et Fabien
Lambert d'avoir accepté notre invitation
si vous êtes intéressé la Fête de la
Nature à ben c'est demain après-midi de
13h30 à 21h et à plaisir c'est jusqu'à
dimanche prochain rendez-vous sur les
sites Internet des mairies de Beynes et
plaisir pour retrouver toutes les
informations et la nature est aussi
célébrée dans d'autres villes des
Yvelines à carrière-sous-poissy le parc
départemental du Peuple de l'Herbe
organise un grand village de la nature
samedi prochain de 14h à 19h au
programme des ateliers des expositions
et des spectacles pour les plus
aventureux Verneuil-sur-Seine prévoit
une chasse au trésor dans la forêt où il
vous faudra retrouver les traces des
animaux ce sera samedi de 10 heures à
16h et rendez-vous également à la Maison
de l'Environnement à Magny-les-Hameaux
samedi prochain de 15h à 17h si vous
voulez tout savoir sur les
hérissons et parce que notre département
est riche en activité nous avons été
rejoint par Lucie Saidi bonsoir bonsoir
et Mario Gervais bonsoir alors vous
allez nous parler d'un festival qui est
complètement dédié aux étudiants si on
en parlera dans quelques instants mais
avant je me tourne vers vous Christophe
Bodin ce weekend on pourra aussi
également découvrir le 32e Salon des
Arts de Montigny le Bretonneux alors
vous êtes l'invité d'honneur vous êtes
aussi artiste peintre qu'est-ce qu'on
pourra découvrir sur ce 32ème Salon des
Arts à Montigny-le-Bretonneux si on
connaît pas alors comme chaque année
donc cette conservateur des arts
Montigny il y a 70 artistes donc il y a
beaucoup de techniques en fait chaque
artiste a un tableau donc on a des
techniques qui sont très variées
il y a de l'acrylique il y a de l'huile
il y a de l'aquarelle on voit plein de
formats différents et puis donc moi-même
j'expose une dizaine de tableaux en tant
qu'invité d'honneur et je montre cette
fois-ci pour la première fois une toute
nouvelle collection donc ça sera la
primeur pour les visiteurs voilà alors
est-ce que vous pouvez nous en dire un
petit peu plus sur cette nouvelle
exposition oui alors cette nouvelle
collection elle est axée toujours sur
les nuages et aussi sur les textures
donc on y retrouve du sable décollage un
petit peu de papier de soie et voilà il
faut découvrir les couleurs les couleurs
sont assez j'étais vraiment travaillé
sur la partie col couleur pour pour
développer
le rêve la partie un peu onirique de de
cette de cette peinture et alors
l'objectif de cet événement de ce salon
des arts c'est aussi de promouvoir de
mettre en avant les artistes locaux du
territoire tout à fait tout à fait
moi-même ça fait depuis de nombreuses
années que je le fais c'est comme ça que
j'ai commencé en faisant des petites
expositions petit à petit et puis ça
donne l'occasion à tout le monde de
pouvoir présenter un premier tableau et
puis après de prendre confiance et puis
de commencer à qui c'est une carrière on
sait jamais on a rendez-vous important
j'ai l'impression ah oui oui tout à fait
tout à fait moi je suis très très
ancré dans le local et je trouve que
c'est super important aussi bien de
faire des choses au local que national
que international aussi en fait et alors
pour finir en beauté cet événement
mercredi 31 mai il y aura la remise des
prix quelles sont ses prix est-ce que
vous pouvez nous expliquer oui alors
effectivement chaque année on a le prix
du public on a le prix de la ville donc
on a de des récompenses pour célébrer la
personne qui selon le jury ou selon le
public à
fait un tableau qui va se démarquer et
qui méritera une distinction et alors
quelle est la récompense j'imagine qu'il
y a un prix pour la plus belle peinture
la plus belle culture
donc on a appris du public on a appris
du jury et voilà donc c'est ça
fonctionne comme ça alors en parallèle
vous travaillez également sur un autre
projet avec une artiste turque c'est une
œuvre qui que vous allez mettre aux
enchères pour venir en aide au sinistré
du tremblement de terre qui a eu lieu en
Turquie en février dernier donc ça c'est
une belle histoire parce que c'est
commencer par une rencontre toute simple
on s'est rencontré au Grand Palais et
puis comme on était voisin on a un petit
peu discuté et bon on a parlé
effectivement de catastrophe en Turquie
et on s'est dit qu'est-ce qu'on pourrait
faire et on a on a posé l'idée de faire
un tableau à quatre mains donc le
tableau représente une jeune fille qui
sort des décombres avec donc l'espoir
c'est quelque chose de positif et un
fond abstrait donc on a travaillé à 80
j'ai commencé je lui ai envoyé le
tableau en Turquie le tableau va être
exposé en
Istanbul dans de quelques jours et puis
après le tableau revient en France et
deuxième étape on va le vendre aux
enchères pour rassembler les fonds et
donner ses fonds aux victimes c'est
assez inédit comme expérience c'est la
première fois que vous travaillez dans
ces conditions comme ça oui tout à fait
tout à fait j'avais déjà fait des
tableaux à quatre mains mais dans un
contexte comme celui-ci c'est une belle
histoire alors depuis combien de temps
est-ce que vous êtes artiste peintre
j'ai commencé à peindre en 2007 donc
c'était une vocation tardive parce que
j'avais déjà 37 ans et puis comme je
vous disais ça commençait avec un
premier dessin un deuxième et puis bah
de fil en aiguille voilà c'est on peut
avoir une carrière qui se développe
l'inspiration
pour créer des nouvelles choses alors
l'inspiration moi j'essaie vraiment de
ne pas trop réfléchir de me laisser
porter par par les émotions parfois par
la musique et ça donne des choses assez
intéressantes il y a aussi une technique
que j'utilise un petit peu moins
maintenant mais que j'utilisais beaucoup
avant en fait je j'imaginais que le
tableau était déjà fini je faisais une
petite sieste et quand je me réveillais
et ben en fait le tableau coulait
beaucoup plus facilement et ça je l'ai
expérimenté à plein de reprises et ça
fonctionne vraiment c'est étonnant et
est-ce que vous vous testez différentes
techniques de peinture toujours toujours
il faut pas s'endormir il faut il faut
essayer de d'ajouter par exemple de la
craie ou des marqueurs toutes sortes de
choses en fait tout est possible on peut
détourner des outils aussi pour faire
des griffures pour enlever des éléments
faire des collages enfin vraiment il y a
la peinture ce qui est génial c'est
qu'il y a pas de limite c'est que
l'esprit notre esprit qui nous limite
donc il faut y aller quoi et alors pour
revenir un petit peu au Salon des Arts
est-ce que c'est aussi l'occasion pour
vous de avec d'autres artistes de vous
faire un réseau oui bien sûr bien sûr
bien sûr pour le notamment le soir du
finissage auquel tout le monde est
invité d'ailleurs et bien l'occasion ça
sera de rencontrer tous les artistes au
locaux de rencontrer aussi peut-être des
galeries de rencontrer des
professionnels donc oui oui c'est
vraiment un moment très important pour
socialiser parce que c'est vrai qu'en
tant que peintre on est souvent dans
notre dans notre studio en train de
peindre tout seul donc le moment où on
peut s'exprimer et puis échanger avec
d'autres c'est vraiment super
intéressant est-ce que vous avez déjà eu
un sur un tableau ou pour le travail
d'un artiste en particulier oui oui bien
sûr bien sûr bien sûr notamment quand je
participe aux expositions au Grand
Palais ou aux Carrousel du Louvre il y a
forcément quelque chose qui va me
toucher parce que c'est grandiose oui on
peut être qu'impressionné par certains
certains tableaux de par leur taille
leur technique leur sensibilité et c'est
très riche merci beaucoup Christophe
Bodin d'avoir accepté notre invitation
alors si vous êtes intéressé le 32e
Salon des Arts de Montigny le Bretonneux
se tiendra jusqu'au mercredi 31 mai au
conservatoire des arts la remise des
prix aura lieu mercredi prochain à 19h
et puis après avoir parlé d'art on va
maintenant parler de musique la deuxième
édition du festival inter filière
revient ce samedi 27 mai au domaine de
Courson c'est l'événement étudiant de
l'Université de Paris Saclay et pour en
parler avec nous Mario Gervais le
président du comité d'organisation et
Lucie Saidi l'organisatrice du pôle
musique logistique alors c'est la
deuxième édition de ce festival est-ce
que vous pouvez nous rappeler l'objectif
de cet événement
donc en fait il y a un objectif triple
au festival de l'Inter filière le
premier objectif d'abord c'est permettre
aux étudiants de qui viennent de
différentes milieux différentes
formations de pouvoir se rencontrer
l'idée c'est vraiment de faire en sorte
que toutes les filières de l'université
d'où le nom participent à l'événement le
second objectif j'ai envie de dire c'est
de rassembler les associations parce que
on est un festival qui se co-organise
entre une dizaine d'associations de
l'université
et le troisième c'est pas trop compliqué
d'organiser ce festival avec une dizaine
d'associations et bah écoutez si ça a
été un petit défi d'accorder beaucoup de
gens beaucoup de beaucoup d'associations
différentes mais bon c'est aussi un
petit peu notre vocation à rassembler
les associations et justement c'est ça
me permet aussi d'enchaîner sur le
troisième objectif qui est de montrer la
vie étudiante de Paris Saclay voilà au
sein de ce festival donc voilà les trois
trois objectifs principaux j'ai envie de
te dire alors le premier donc vous
l'avez dit ce sont de regrouper toutes
les filières toutes les filières sont
concernées en quoi est-ce que c'est très
important pour vous
c'est très important parce que il se
trouve que dans Paris Saclay il y a un
vrai sujet au niveau de la communication
entre les différents étudiants des
différentes filières quand on est par
exemple à la fac c'est difficile
d'interagir avec des gens des écoles et
réciproquement voilà l'UVSQ Paris disons
que c'est une énorme université donc
c'est très important pour nous d'avoir
un événement fédérateur au moins un
annuel qui permette voilà de faire en
sorte que tout le monde passe du temps
ensemble se rencontrent on est quand
même dans étudiant de la même université
c'est dommage de jamais interagir au
cours de l'année donc là au moins on
donne l'occasion aux gens de pouvoir
interagir alors Lucie quels sont les
évolutions par rapport à la première
édition est-ce qu'il y a des choses qui
qui vont changer cette année alors il y
a pas mal de choses qui vont changer
effectivement
moi la première édition je l'ai faite en
tant que festivalière pas en tant
qu'organisatrice donc je peux vous
donner l'expérience que j'ai vécu et
donc nous les petits changements que je
vois
déjà ne serait-ce que d'un point de vue
logistique cette année pour faciliter le
trafic ou les transitions on a décidé de
choisir d'avoir deux barres de manière à
ne pas avoir forcément beaucoup de queue
ce genre de choses
il y aura plus d'associations qui seront
présentes aussi cette année on aura une
vraie présence pour notre associative
avec chacune des assauts qui va pouvoir
présenter ce qu'il fait durant l'année
et pourquoi pas du coup
pouvoir intéresser des nouveaux
étudiants de les rejoindre
et puis
je sais pas qu'est-ce que tu as envie de
rajouter musical peut-être
quelle est la programmation
au niveau musical beaucoup de choses ont
changé d'abord on a on a une tête
d'affiche cette année ce qui est quand
même important c'est un DJ de musique
électronique qui s'appelle gravity
auquel j'accorde beaucoup de enfin
j'apprécie beaucoup ce qu'il fait donc
ça me fait vraiment plaisir qu'il a été
accepté par le pôle musique
pour avoir le gravité avec lui tout à
fait et puis aussi j'ai envie de
rajouter un point très important c'est
que cette année on a mis en place des
navettes parce que c'est le domaine de
Courson est quand même assez
inaccessible pour des étudiants qui sont
pas véhiculés donc on a fait l'effort
pour eux de mettre en place la
logistique des bus et voilà je pense que
les deux gros changements c'est
essentiellement les navettes et la tête
d'affiche du coup ça fait quand même
quelque chose de plus complet voilà
depuis qualitatif il y aura également
des gros étudiants qui qui vont jouer
aussi pendant le festival tout à fait on
pas une des associations de la fac qui
s'appelle campus en musique qui est une
des associations qui organisent le
festival et comme ils ont fait l'année
dernière cette année ils ont organisé ce
qu'on a ce qu'ils ont appelé les
backstage donc qui était un concert qui
rassemblait plusieurs groupes qui
étudiant de Paris Saclay ou en lien avec
la fac et c'était les étudiants qui
étaient présents au concert ce soir-là
qui pouvait voter pour choisir leur
groupe préféré et du coup comme ça on a
eu deux groupes qui ont été choisis le
premier qui s'appelle Rocket qui fait du
hard rock et le deuxième qui s'appelle
aplace to gros et qui est un
groupe composé essentiellement
d'étudiants de Paris Saclay il se sera
du rock aussi ce sera du rock alternatif
et alors quels sont les autres
animations autour de la musique est-ce
que il y aura je sais pas on m'a parlé
de de
se jeter dans le vide
[Rires]
par le morceau en fait ça c'est encore
une autre amélioration qu'on a qu'on a
apporté au festival on a on a mis une
animation en plus qui est faite par
notre partenaire ennemi donc en fait
l'idée c'est qu'on installe un grand
coussin d'air une grande plateforme à 10
mètres de haut et en fait on permet aux
étudiants de de sauter de la plateforme
jusque cette espèce de grand coussin
d'air et tout ça c'est gratuit donc
c'est inclus dans le dans la place et
honnêtement je pense qu'il y en a qui
les amateurs de sensations fortes vont
vraiment apprécier c'est une expérience
quoi vivre
et vous que c'est un volant je pense que
je pourrais le faire
je compte le faire en tout cas
et alors est-ce que vous avez eu
quelques difficultés à organiser ce
festival est-ce que vous avez rencontré
quelques difficultés
d'abord c'est compliqué au niveau
financier parce que nous on est une
association qui a été créée en septembre
là donc on est parti vraiment de zéro
faut imaginer qu'on n'avait pas d'argent
pas de compte bancaire pas de pas de
structure administrative en septembre
donc il faut quand même rassembler c'est
un projet quand même assez chiffres donc
c'est plus de 100000 euros donc il
faudrait réussir à convaincre les
partenaires institutionnels je pense à
l'UVSQ mais je pense aussi à Paris
Saclay donc encore Paris Saclay je pense
aussi à la communauté d'agglomération de
Paris-Saclay donc faut réussir à les
convaincre pour nous financer en partie
donc ça ça a été une très très grosse
difficulté puis après je dirais la
difficulté de la logistique voilà nous
on n'est pas enfin moi personnellement
je suis étudiants Lucie aussi on n'est
pas professionnel donc forcément faut
trouver du temps à se dégager pour faire
des réunions appeler les prestataires
voilà donc c'est quand même un gros
programme ouais c'est ça c'est vrai
qu'on est on est tous étudiants moi
actuellement j'ai la chance de suivre
une formation d'événements ciel mais je
suis la seule qui fait parmi les 21
organisateurs qui qui suit une formation
comme ça donc pour des gens qui ont pas
l'habitude de gérer d'autres gros
événements et forcément c'est un
challenge et alors est-ce qu'il est
possible de de réserver d'avoir encore
une place à tout à fait
tout à fait on espère que vous prendrez
votre place suite à l'émission
on a une billetterie sur le site de camp
ma camp ma app et aujourd'hui les places
sont encore à 20 euros donc si vous
voulez prendre votre place il faut
essentiellement aller sur notre site
Instagram interfilaire tout le monde va
le trouver parce que voilà c'est assez
facile
va s'afficher en bas de notre écran
et en fait dans le dans la biographie de
ce compte Instagram il y a tous les
liens pour prendre sa place et c'est
ouvert à tout le monde francilien
étudiant voilà on essaie c'est un
festival organisé par des étudiants mais
on vise toute l'Île-de-France tous les
Franciliens intéressés et bien merci
beaucoup Mario Gervais et Lucie d'être
venu sur notre plateau pour répondre à
nos questions alors je le rappelle je le
festival inter filière aura lieu ce
samedi 27 mai au domaine de Courson dans
l'Essonne vous retrouverez toutes les
informations sur le compte Instagram qui
s'affiche juste en dessous allez c'est
l'heure maintenant de passer à notre
chronique sur le bien-être animal
[Musique]
et donc c'est avec ATIS Barret vous la
voyez elle est en train de nous
rejoindre en plateau bonsoir à tous
bonsoir Mathilde alors le jeudi vous
venez nous parler de nos amis à quatre
pattes et ce soir vous êtes venu avec
deux chiens deux gros chiens
era et nouba
seul donc avec era inouba donc nouvelle
chien noir du coup le chien noir donc
qui a 6 ans qui pèse 58 kg bon le poids
idéal que je souhaiterais avoir
et
era donc elle a 4 ans et elle pèse 56 kg
donc c'est des Terres Neuves c'est
particularité c'est des chiens de
sauvetage en mer et elles ont des pattes
qui sont pas le mais si on touche sur
leurs pattes vous verrez elles ont elles
ont des palmes voilà c'est des chiens
qui sont vraiment très très fidèles qui
sont très loyaux ils sont grands et
impressionnants ils sont vraiment très
gentils c'est des chiens idéal pour pour
les enfants alors juste artiste vous
pouvez garder un oeil sur eux mais je
vais vous demander quand même de vous
tourner vers le micro pour qu'on puisse
bien vous entendez pas grave et j'en
profite pour accueillir de nouveaux
journalistes de la rédaction de TV 78
Gabriel Gontier et Nicolas dandry
bonsoir bonsoir alors Gabriel avec vous
on verra les idées de sortie à faire
dans les Yvelines pour ce week-end et
Nicolas vous allez nous présenter le
quiz tout à l'heure ce sera sur la
nature je crois
alors ATIS vous nous disiez que donc ce
sont des chiens de sauvetage en mer ça
consiste en quoi en fait leur rôle alors
le rôle bah écoutez très travailleuse
d'intervenir de sauver les humains mais
aujourd'hui leur rôle c'est également de
donner la joie dans les familles parce
que c'est des chiens avec lesquels on
s'attache énormément
et alors il me semble qu'aujourd'hui on
est censé fêter leur anniversaire
un gâteau pour leur anniversaire elle le
mérite tellement que j'ai fait un gâteau
hier soir à 23h30 ah oui voilà ils sont
tellement bons que les enfants sont
arrivés en disant c'est pour nous j'ai
dit et non c'est pour les rail ou pas et
alors pour faire cette recette de gâteau
vous êtes inspiré dans le livre oui je
me suis inspirée d'un livre que je vais
aller récupérer alors j'avais posé là
voilà
donc j'ai cherché une recette j'allais
pas faire n'importe quoi pour
era Noba donc j'ai pris un livre de
Valérie Drouet qui était un cuisinier et
donc que j'ai pris les le livre
s'appelle les babines canines de les
éditions de la Martinière donc c'est un
livre qui donne des recettes équilibrées
on a beaucoup de thèmes
on le voit à l'écran on voit la
couverture
à l'écran
oui je veux l'ouvrir pour montrer donc
les différentes thématiques que je tiens
les laisse en même temps
donc on a les gamelles pour chien
délicat
bon mais peut-être que me le donner pour
que ce soit plus simple pour vous je
connais pas les pages par cœur et
les gamelles pour chien Chic
on a aussi donc le la partie des gâteaux
et puis on a la partie également
friandise et donc je me suis inspirée de
cette page là où il y a également
era innova pour confectionner donc leur
gâteau leur beurre des cakes
et alors ça représente quoi ces
différentes catégories et c'est par
rapport au gabarit du chien c'est par
rapport à son appétit alors si par
rapport à son appétit par rapport au
thème par rapport à l'humeur par rapport
aussi à votre humeur parce que vous
allez vous mettre en connexion avec le
chien vous allez pouvoir manger la même
chose que lui et
elle est toute joyeuse elles aiment les
caméras
donc en fonction par exemple vous avez
les gamelles pour chien délicat c'est
des recettes qui sont assez marrantes
donc en fonction de l'appétit vous avez
préféré c'est vraiment les la
chinoiseries d'accord
un petit clin d'oeil au viennoiserie ou
rien à voir alors non chinoiserie
chinois chinoiserie peut-être parce que
c'est avec du poisson avec il y a du
colin il y a du il y a du saumon et vous
pourrez partager donc cette recette avec
avec votre chien autour de la table
parce que c'est totalement équilibré
donc les chiens peuvent manger du
poisson sans aucun problème sans aucun
problème toutes les recettes ont été
faites avec un vétérinaire donc tout est
équilibré vous avez la partie aussi
friandise la partie friandise moi j'ai
hâte de partager des friandises avec era
et nouba déjà la friandise c'est pour
instaurer une bonne relation de
confiance avec avec le chien et le
muesli doggy ça je trouve ça marrant le
musclé douillet ça c'est la prochaine
recette que je ferai et que je mangerai
avec era et Noba
et alors du coup vous êtes inspiré de ce
livre pour faire le gâteau
d'anniversaire de era et nouba vous
l'avez apporté en plateau apporter en
plateau il y a quoi comme ingrédient
dedans les ingrédients donc j'ai fait
rester ma liste de courses aujourd'hui
les carottes les œufs la farine du
poulet de la crème liquide donc c'est
vraiment des ingrédients qui sont très
simples des ingrédients que vous avez
forcément dans votre frigo et que vous
allez partager avec votre chien ça va
être appétissant il y aura tout à
l'intérieur les oméga 3 les oméga 6 vous
avez aucun problème de vie chimique à
l'intérieur
du coup je vous propose Baptiste
[Rires]
la bonne odeur de gâteaux que j'ai alors
vous allez goûter aussi du gâteau je
pouvais on va goûter c'est Nicolas
Gabriel
je leur ai même ramené des cadeaux
donc gâteau bon il fait chaud c'est un
petit peu fondu au niveau de la crème
c'est pas la même présentation que le
bien
alors
je crois qu'on a prévu une petite
musique nous aussi voilà pour faire les
choses comme il faut
les cadeaux et alors qu'est-ce que c'est
ces cadeaux alors c'est pour faire des
selfies c'est des balles c'est des
balles
comme ça
[Musique]
d'accord donc en fait il y a une caméra
dans la balle comme ça ça va être son
téléphone et puis on fait des selfies
avec d'accord donc je vais prendre les
assiettes
de goûter est-ce que est-ce qu'il vous
semble appétissant ce gâteau Nicolas
Gabriel Céline
je vous donne d'abord vos pas parce que
j'ai pas mis de croquettes sur les
vôtres
[Rires]
partage avec Céline
on va équilibrer
ils ont l'air ils sont partis c'est
parti j'enlève la bougie voilà
[Rires]
c'est bon
et ouais elles adorent
voilà
je sais pas combien de temps vous avez
mis pour faire le gâteau à titre mais en
deux secondes c'est fini
pour toi aussi
voilà
donc c'est vraiment très facile à faire
et bah les soirées vous sentez seul vous
pouvez préparer un plateau pour vous et
pour le chat vous partagez tous les deux
en tout cas
bien la crème sur le noir vous avez un
Obba elle prend un peu plus son temps
pour le manger elle déguste elle est par
contre il y a plus de gâteaux là pour
[Rires]
est-ce que vous voulez aussi goûter le
gâteau moi je goûte après vous
alors je vous laisse ma part si vous
voulez
Gabriel vous avez pas tenté
ça avec Nicolas
est joueur comme moi voilà
[Rires]
c'est aussi bon qu'il y a les miroir
s du chien
et laquelle goutte ce gâteau du coup
c'est un goût un peu original du poulet
voilà
on prend pas le kilos pendant un
anniversaire
merci beaucoup Baptiste barré pour pour
toutes ces nouvelles découvertes à
chaque fois vous nous faites découvrir
de nouveaux horizons merci Mathilde
allez on poursuit cette page loisirs
avec vos idées de sortie Gabriel comme
chaque jeudi à l'approche du week-end
vous nous partagez vos meilleurs plans
dans les Yvelines on commence par quoi
ce soir bien on commence par le théâtre
de Poissy Mathilde le théâtre de Poissy
qui accueille Michel Fugain donc Poissy
qui dansera sur des airs de Michel
Fugain vendredi soir pour fêter ses 80
ans le chanteur revient avec un nouveau
spectacle Fugain fait bande à part à ses
côtés sa bande comme il les appelle des
gens pas comme les autres qui lui ont
inspiré le nom de son spectacle en
musique et en chanson je suis bien
reprend ses plus grands titres dans un
spectacle à la fois joyeux simple et
convivial je vous propose qu'on écoute
un qui risque que vous de vous rappeler
quelques souvenirs
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
importants
venez dans ces temps la rue c'est le nez
plus défendu c'est la fête la fête
en vérité je vous le dis c'est le
paradis c'est la fête
bon j'imagine que vous avez reconnu les
titres autour du plateau chante la vie
chante la fête patrimoine de la musique
française le concert est à 20h30
vendredi soir et quelques places sont
encore disponibles et on reste en
musique Gabriel mais dans un registre un
peu différent on part avec à Versailles
oui après deux éditions sold out
Versailles électro revient ce week-end
samedi les terrasses du château de
Versailles accueilleront les clubber
pour une soirée d'exception en tête
d'affiche kungs ou encore Martin Solveig
la première partie sera assurée par
upsilon artiste montant de la scène
électro le DJ 7 sera accompagné d'un
show de pyrotechnie autour du château
début de la soirée prévu à 18h30 si vous
êtes intéressé vous devez prendre vos
places sur le site internet qui
s'affiche en bas de votre écran il y
aura pas de vente à proximité du château
et alors pour ceux qui voudraient
peut-être passer un week-end un peu plus
tranquille un peu plus calme la balade
de printemps des 400 coups revient où il
le rendez vous incontournable Yvelines
moi du spectacle vivant revient jusqu'au
10 juin pour ces balades de printemps
l'association Les 400 coups vous propose
6 représentations au programme des
comptes du théâtre des lectures ou
encore des poèmes visuels et musicaux
l'objectif de l'association faire venir
le théâtre où il n'a pas l'habitude
d'aller dans des théâtres des
bibliothèques mais aussi des écoles pour
le rendre accessible à tous eux de la
Brusse directeur artistique à l'origine
des programmations nous expliquent
donc les quatre sont cools c'est une
association qui a pour mission de
développer
la présence du spectacle vivant jeune
public dans la vallée de la Seine on
s'est rendu compte avec les différents
partenaires et avec la collectivité que
s'il y avait des il y a des propositions
il y a des théâtres qui sont qui sont
sur cette communauté mais il y a aussi
beaucoup d'endroits où il y a pas de
théâtre il y a des zones rurales assez
éloigner de tous les théâtres donc la
volonté était de pouvoir s'adresser à
tous et en allant dans des endroits où
la fréquentation des oeuvres est
compliquée et peu possible quand on va
avoir à se déplacer en voiture etc alors
l'avantage de ces spectacles c'est
qu'ils sont accessibles dès 6 mois pour
les tarifs comptés entre 3 et 8 euros à
noter que sur les six spectacles il y en
a quand même quatre qui sont gratuits
c'est bien et on part maintenant du côté
des Clayes-sous-Bois où le geek-up
festival revient pour une deuxième
édition oui avis aux fans de la culture
pop et japonaise après le succès
rencontré l'année dernière le geek Up
Festival revient de nombreuses exposants
sont au
200 exposants merci beaucoup Gabriel
Gontier pour toutes ces idées alors
comme d'habitude petit tour de plateau
est-ce qu'il y a quelque chose qui vous
tente plus qu'une autre je crois que
Céline vous serez au geek-up festival
c'est déjà prévu et vous Nicolas Gabriel
brocante pour dénicher des perles moi
plutôt Versailles
brocante mais comme j'ai du mal à me
lever à 4h du matin pour dénicher les
bonnes affaires toute la journée en
général
vous pouvez trouver encore
allez c'est l'heure du traditionnel quiz
du jeudi Nicolas dandry ce soir vous
allez nous challenger sur la nature dans
les Yvelines la nature dans les Yvelines
la nature dans tous ses états ça peut
être dans vos jardins ça peut être dans
les grandes forêts ça peut être aussi
dans les anciens sujets de TV 78 alors
on va commencer avec la première
question quelle est la surface couverte
par les forêts dans le département des
Yvelines sachant que
c'est en hectare que je demande un
chiffre à 10000 prêts
[Musique]
moi je dirais 45
1050000
on va dire 60 000 58000
secondes
c'est Céline qui est la plus proche il y
a 68000 hectares de forêt dans le
département des Yvelines à la fois des
forêts domaniales des forêts aussi
gérées par le département des Yvelines
ou encore des forêts privées pour la
deuxième question je vous propose de
regarder cet extrait concernant un arbre
remarquable sujet réalisé en 2021
regardez cet arbre remarquable a été
planté ici il y a plus de 120 ans sa
spécificité c'est que et bien il est
très ancien bien sûr ce sont des
variétés qui sont plutôt en voie de
disparition il est en très bon état
sanitaire il fait environ on avait
évalué à 17 18 mètres de hauteur à peu
près une circonférence qui fait 2 mètres
80 quand même et puis l'aspect on le
voit bien de l'écorce aussi quand ça
part en vrille comme ça c'est
caractéristique des arbres anciens
où
il est si dans quelle commune cet arbre
[Musique]
est-ce que ce serait une commune de 50
ans en Yvelines c'est possible
[Musique]
réponse Élancourt
Villepreux
deux bonnes réponses Coignières ce
Poirier Saint-Martin désigné arbres
remarquable en 2016 et si tu es à
Coignières un partout pour Céline
Mathilde et Athis 0 pour Gabriel vous
avez encore quatre autres questions
Gabriel regardez cet extrait d'un
reportage réalisé pardon excusez-moi ma
troisième question alors il existe une
maison des insectes à carrière sous
Poissy une structure créée par l'OPI
l'office pour les insectes et leur
environnement quand est-ce que cette
maison des insectes a vu le jour dans le
département
alors ce qui est dommage c'est que
c'était dans ce journal dans le 7 8 de
ce soir donc la réponse il fallait bien
écouter le 7 8 ce soir j'ai dit depuis
2017 la maison des insectes à carrière
sous Poissy donc je dirais 2017
bravo Mathilde Mathilde décidément est
une très très bonne présentatrice du 7 8
effectivement c'était en 2017 donc vous
prenez l'avantage sur cette question et
oui c'était dans le reportage de Julien
Leroy diffusé en début de journal en
début de journal pour la Fête de la
Nature exactement quatrième question
question intitulée dans votre jardin
regardez cette photo et dites moi
qu'est-ce que c'est
[Musique]
c'est pas facile
qu'est-ce qui va pousser dans mon dans
mon jardin c'est mon jardin qu'est-ce
qui va
bravo this effectivement c'est un c'est
une pousse d'aubergine voilà j'espère en
avoir beaucoup dans mon jardin
c'est une photo prise ce matin voilà
au niveau du sport Mathilde 2 ATIS 2 1
pour Céline Gabriel
vous pouvez égaliser regardez cet
extrait c'est un reportage réalisé en
2004 lors d'une classe découverte
le position quelle est sa forme
les légumes ils sont cultivés et c'est
parti carte en main les élèves du
collège Einstein de Magny-les-Hameaux
doivent tout d'abord découvrir l'endroit
où ils vont vivre pendant une semaine de
l'intérieur de la maison de la croix du
bois aux forêts environnantes on va leur
faire découvrir le patrimoine de la
croix du bois et un petit peu des
villages environnants donc on va leur
faire un petit peu visiter la forêt leur
faire découvrir tout ce qui est nature
au sens large du terme et les initiés à
la calligraphie aux techniques du
Moyen-Âge pour les enluminures autre
découverte celle de la vie en commun et
des règles à respecter pas toujours
facile
l'oreille et la bouche et bien pendant
le Conseil on adopte que celle là le
fait de vivre la vie tous ensemble y
compris les moments informels ça change
les relations entre entre les Anglais
s'il vous plaît
l'établissement concerné par cette
classe découverte et la commune où est
située cet établissement
on entend croix du bois croix du bois
c'est là où a lieu la classe découverte
quelle est l'établissement qui est
concerné alors c'est un magniliamo
effectivement c'est un demi point pour
cette établissement je ne sais pas mais
je crois qu'on l'a entendu dans le sud
oui
Céline très bonne réponse il s'agit de
l'école primaire Albert Einstein à
Magny-les-Hameaux vous égalisez Céline
deux pour Mathilde pour Céline 2 pour
ATIS zéro pour Gabriel allez dernière
question c'est la question qui va
départager ou pas d'ailleurs parce que
si vous répondez pour l'honneur
exactement nouvelle extrait toujours en
2004 direction Guyancourt
Chloé a 8 ans et plante aujourd'hui en
compagnie du maire de la commune
François de lignée un drôle d'arbustes
qu'elle a fait pousser elle-même il y a
deux ans lorsqu'elle la ramassé sa
n'était qu'un petit gland il vient de de
la campagne parce que quand j'ai été
chez ma mamie et on a été un foret et
j'ai dit de prendre un chêne enfin ma
maman m'a dit de prendre la chaîne pour
voir comment ça va ça va pousser comment
il va grandir une soixantaine d'arbustes
ont été plantés début de Leia des
forsythia et des sauges et selon la
formule consacrée à la Sainte Catherine
tout bois prend racine en réalité
l'origine du dicton se limite à la
réussite des bouturage à cette période
la plantation d'arbres est conseillé
d'octobre à avril
alors est-ce que vous pouvez me dire
quel est le dicton qui est cité dans ce
reportage et à votre avis qu'est-ce qui
à quel moment a été tourné ce reportage
tout bois prend racine
à la Sainte Catherine tout bois prend
racine tout prend racine c'est ça
la question qui va vous départager à
votre avis ça a été tourné quand est-ce
que c'est la Sainte Catherine au moins
le mois s'il vous plaît c'est dur comme
question Nicolas
je ne connais pas de Catherine
au moins le mois et on entend parler de
d'un délai du mois non vous l'avez pas
en automne donc je dirais octobre ou
novembre
vous dites quoi octobre ou novembre
je crois que la bonne réponse est là
donc je vais dire novembre
matin pour ce soir c'est bien novembre
il s'agit du 25 novembre donc là le
dicton c'est à la Sainte Catherine tout
bois prend racine c'est le 25 novembre
et c'est le jour de la Sainte-Catherine
c'est une période propice pour la
plantation d'arbres et d'arbustes étant
au début de l'hiver voilà merci beaucoup
Nicolas dandry vous nous avez promis un
quiz facile ce soir j'ai trouvé qu'il
était un petit peu dur quand même
merci beaucoup en tout cas Nicolas
dandry pour nous faire vivre tous les
jeudis ce traditionnel quiz où on en
apprend toujours un petit peu plus sur
le département des Yvelines c'est
bientôt la fin de cette émission mais
juste avant de se quitter je vous
propose de jeter un dernier coup d'oeil
à la météo de demain
[Musique]
demain matin le soleil sera toujours au
beau fixe dans les Yvelines les
températures commencent à être estivales
il fera 13 degrés le matin à Houdan
Rambouillet et Versailles et 14 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie dans l'après-midi le
soleil brillera toujours côté
température comptait environ 21 à 22
degrés en moyenne et pour les prévisions
météo de ce weekend Gabriel qu'elles
t'ont fera-t-il et bien vous aurez un
week-end ensoleillé Mathilde samedi
matin le soleil est omniprésent les
températures seront comprises entre 11
et 13 degrés l'après-midi même tendance
compter 22 degrés à Houdan et Versailles
23 à Mantes-la-Jolie et 24 degrés à
Rambouillet dimanche dans la matinée le
fera 13 degrés à Houdan et Rambouillet
14 degrés à Versailles et
Mantes-la-Jolie l'après-midi les
températures seront comprises entre 23
et 24 degrés merci beaucoup Gabriel
Gontier c'est la fin de cette émission
merci d'avoir été avec nous je vous
souhaite une belle soirée sur TV 78 et
un excellent weekend prenez soin de vous
[Musique]